marie-anne Terezin blingo Lumumba est
née en 1755 en-échantillon elle se marie
avec avi Pullum panel de besa en 1770 un
cousin éloigné ils ont 13 enfants
nés entre 1771 et 1797 dont neuf ont survécu
et occuperont des postes élevés ainsi qu'en
l'île Bourbon comme en
France une de ses filles Mélanie
épouse le comte de valais en 1799
Ministre sous Charles X et
Louis XVIII après le décès de son mari en
1800 ce riche propriétaire foncier
profite des conseils de ses fils Joseph et Charles
pour rester à la tête de  sa
propriété à Saji lille depuis quarante ans
et pour orienter la production vers la
culture de la canne à sucre en tant que
catholique pratiquante elle possède une chapelle domestique
dans sa propriété à sahjhan avec une
architecture originale un lieu de culte
pour les personnes vivant dans les parties supérieures de l'
échantillon et  pour ses nombreuses esclaves
et une maîtresse, son
esprit éclairé est la raison pour laquelle elle fut nommée
seconde providence au cours de la première
moitié du 19ème siècle. Aujourd'hui, une
légende noire de Madame de Beste subsiste
originaire de la fin du 19ème
siècle mais se développe principalement  dans les
années 1970, elle fait d'elle un être cruel
dénué de toute humanité et dont l'âme est
condamnée à payer ses crimes au
fond de la fournaise du volcan
dans l'oratorio seul notable peut Oh à l'
envers l'œuvre écrite en 1998 par le
poète bouddhiste gamellia  évoque sa
présence elle arrive
ne se cache plus les uns dans un autre
sommeil rêve
elle a perdu sa blancheur la folie de
l'absolu elle tombe et surgit un
camp de rêves pour un peuple d'usine et
sur les nôtres silence de vérité bleue